a victory for the prime minister but far
from convincingly the vote in favour uh
of having confidence in boris johnson's
theater was 211 votes and the vote
against was 148 votes
and therefore
i can announce that the parliamentary
party does have confidence
[Applause]
a raucous reaction from boris johnson's
supporters but there's no disguising the
enormity of the 148 mps who voted
against their own leader
i think it's a convincing result a
decisive result on what it what it means
is that as a
as a government we can move on and focus
on the stuff that i think really matters
to people
mr speaker recent feverish speculation
about boris johnson's political future
have been relegated somewhat by last
week's four-day national holiday in
honor of the queen's platinum jubilee
but the public booing which greeted the
prime minister at friday's service of
thanksgiving for the queen was an
ominous indicator
a random sample of london commuters
confirms a certain degree of public
disillusionment i thought that was so
telling that actually that he got booed
i think that was almost like that felt
like a turning point to me actually
despite securing a solid 80 seat
majority in the general election just
two and a half years ago boris johnson
has endured months of controversy and
criticism which have steadily undermined
his authority
chief among them the partygate saga
where johnson and many of his staff were
found to have flouted coveted lockdown
rules at downing street gatherings
johnson became the first pm judge to
have broken the law while in office the
official inquiry into those events
criticized a lack of leadership the
british public are fed up
fed up with a prime minister who
promises big but never delivers
fed up with a prime minister who's
presided over a culture of lies and law
breaking at the heart of government
fed up with a prime minister who is
utterly unfit for the great office that
he holds it's a victory for boris
johnson but hardly a ringing endorsement
of him and his leadership one
commentator on monday said johnson's
appeal within the party was a mile wide
but just an inch deep and so it seems
johnson himself will undoubtedly battle
on fighting tooth and nail to retain his
grip on power but his options are
rapidly dwindling
the current rules mean it will be at
least 12 months before a new confidence
vote can be called but questions about
the prime minister's judgment and
credibility remain unprecedent shows
that surviving a confidence vote often
represents only a stay of execution for
tory leaders rather than a full reprieve
paul brennan al jazeera westminster